and this is coming from the UK Health
Security Agency which is saying that an
estimated 20 people died as a result of
a lab blunder during the pandemic around
39 000 PCR tests were reported as
negative when they were actually
positive this is for a period of six
weeks in September to October of last
year our health correspondent artist
Joshie joins me now with more on this
story and artists this is quite the
Revelation from the UK HSA tell us more
yeah this is an investigation which took
place to try and understand the impact
of those uh tests which were returned as
negative when they should have been
positive people might remember at the
time the UK Health Service Health
Security Agency reported that immensa
the services immensely this private lab
in Wolverhampton in the Midlands had
been suspended while an investigation
took place a lot of people
complained and said we're not sure
whether these test results are accurate
I you know I feel very ill and it's
coming back negative the PCR tests are
coming back negative so what the UK HSA
their investigators have done Sarah Jane
is they've they've put together this
investigation with modeling to try and
understand the impact of all these 39
000 false negatives and they've
calculated that they those tests those
39 000 tests could have led to an extra
55
000 in infections across the south west
of England and then they've worked out
that those 55 000 extra infections given
the prevalence of covid-19 at the time
could have caused up to 20 or 23 deaths
so quite a huge impact from those false
negatives returned by a private lab
which was contracted by NHS test and
Trace during those months in autumn in
2021 and these are the findings now of
that investigation so it
obviously lost loss of life and those 55
000 further infections were at the
heights of the pandemic leading in to
the winter uh very bad news for the UK
HSA and NHS test and Trace which has
been under so much pressure and people
looking back on exactly how effective it
it handled those um investigations and
those infections now more questions will
be asked about the use of private
Laboratories and and testing regimes
contracted out by NHS test and Trace